was machen sie hier bleiben sie doch zu
hause
schreiben sie dem arzt entgegen die
situation ist angespannt droht zu
eskalieren
ich war einen tag lang unterwegs mit
demonstranten in virginia fakten prallen
auf provokation als der ärzte auf wut
der demonstranten
drei stunden vorher treffen sie sich
hier auf einem supermarktparkplatz ihre
autos zu dekorieren wie monika ist nennt
dasteht babys umbringen und trinken das
geht aber gottesdienste mit der familie
besuchen nicht mit anderen worten man
kann aktuell eine abtreibung bekommen
aber nicht in die kirche gehen
so bringen sie neben ihrer protest
botschaft auch ultra konservative
ansichten und ob die ankommen erfahre
ich später es gehe ihnen um die
verfassung sagen menschen wie troja und
julius macht unsere geschäfte und
kirchen wieder auf damit wir wieder
beten und arbeiten können und nicht alle
pleite gehen und alles verlieren wofür
wir gearbeitet haben
es bedeutet dass wir unsere grundrechte
zurückhaben wollen
das gesetz garantiert freiheiten und
werden den bürgern gerade weg sie meinen
damit die ausgangs beschränkungen
glauben aber hinter dem virus stecke
mehr
das alles ist eine einzige verschwörung
um unseren rechtmäßig gewählten
präsidenten zu schaden der sich sehr
darum bemüht hat diesem land zur besten
wirtschaftslage aller zeiten zu helfen
und nun scheint es so als wolle man
diese krise gegen ihn benutzen damit
alle diese forderungen und gedanken
hören und david bringt die demo hatte
mit organisiert viel presse ist gekommen
das freut ihn
im vorfeld wurden die demonstranten aber
von den organisatoren bei facebook
gewarnt
die medien wollten sie in eine
politische ecke stellen
wir sind alle nur einzelpersonen niemand
gehört hier einer größeren gruppe an
na gut manche vielleicht schon aber die
steckt nicht dahinter
das alles hier wurde von sechs leuten
letzten donnerstag am telefon
organisiert auffällig ist aber dass
viele lokalpolitiker und
interessensvertreter da sind alles
republikaner und viele tropfens so
kandidierte john major hier rechts
gerade für einen platz im lokalen
kongress er ist wie viele hier an
abtreibungsgegner und freund der
waffenlobby martha blätter neben ihm
unterstützt den us präsidenten im
wahlkampf
[Musik]
fast jeden tag predigt um die bekämpfung
des virus darf nicht schlimmer sein als
das virus selbst das wird hier gerne
zitiert wenn auch nicht immer ganz
richtig das virus darf nicht schlimmer
sein als seine bekämpfung korrekt
zitiert oder nicht das geht schnell
unter denn es zählt vor allem eins
möglichst laut sein
sie misstrauen medizinischen fakten und
nennen den wichtigsten virologen des
landes anthony fauci der täglich zahlen
und erkenntnisse liefert einen lügner
trumps teils absurden und gefährlichen
ratschlägen hingegen vertrauen sie das
tut auch jason rogers noch eine
republikaner der für den örtlichen
kongress kandidiert
das malaria medikament
hydrochlorothiazid romy ziehen können
erwiesenermaßen menschen wieder gesund
machen
in nur wenigen stunden oder tagen das
belegen studien
es gibt auch welche die sagen dass das
nicht stimmt aber die sind meiner
meinung nach voreingenommene viele hier
glauben das virus könne ihm nichts
anhaben
alle vorsichtsmaßnahmen seien
übertrieben
freedom over 4
unsere freiheit steht über der angst
sagen sie so bedeutet diese freiheit auf
waffen zu besitzen
[Musik]
sie drehen musik auf die einst gegen das
politische establishment geschrieben
wurde
schwenken dazu die farbe der
amerikanischen revolution
sie wird auch gerne von anhängern der
erzkonservativen tea party bewegung
gehisst
es fällt schwer zu glauben dass dieser
protest tatsächlich nur von ein paar
ganz normalen bürgern organisiert
auch mitglieder der sogenannten three
presenter sind gekommen eine gruppierung
innerhalb der extremen rechten
vielleicht verrät er mir deshalb nicht
seinen richtigen namen spricht aber
trotzdem ganz offen
es gibt eine verfassung und bestimmte
grundrechte in diesem land und die
strafe wenn diese verletzt werden dass
der tod
was ich damit sagen möchte ist wenn man
die bürger zu sehr unterdrückt kommt es
zu einer revolution nicht allen hier
sieht man ihre einstellung auf den
ersten blick an
ich hatte mein aha erlebnis durch das
falsche narrativ über die ereignisse vom
elften september
wir wissen dass das gebäude nummer 7
kontrolliert gesprengt wurde
dominic rossi lag ist familienvater und
mit seinen drei kindern heute hier viele
freuen sich darüber dass auch junge
menschen mit demonstrieren
seine tochter die 17-jährige summer wir
gerne öffentlich machen was sie denkt
wir schwimmen ja auch noch in
swimmingpools auch wenn tausende
menschen jedes jahr darin ertrinken
wir können unser leben nicht so
einschränken nur wegen dieses virus für
den großteil der menschen ist es nicht
so gefährlich
das rechtfertigt nicht alles dicht zu
machen was viele hier zudem bestärkt ist
ihr glaube an gott
der soll sie vor corona schützen der
pastor und republikanische abgeordnete
john benjamin stream live raus an seine
gemeinde danke gott für alle die den
preis der freiheit kennen und dafür
kämpfen
die proteste sind ein geschenk für
schaaf
sie richten sich gegen die örtlichen
gouverneur das lenkt ab von seinem
verspäteten nationalen krisen-management
die protestler wie auch der präsident
fordern eine schnelle öffnung des landes
um die wirtschaft wieder anzukurbeln
das ist wichtig für tram mit einer
schwachen wirtschaftsleistung fürchtet
er die wiederwahl im november nicht zu
schaffen
die demonstranten hier heute sind zwar
nicht die mehrheit in diesem land die
meisten amerikaner haben sorge vor einer
zu frühen öffnung noch das kann sich
schnell ändern
viele menschen leiden zurzeit ich habe
ein kleines unternehmen und verliere
alles wofür ich 17 jahre lang gearbeitet
habe wenn wir die wirtschaft nicht
wieder öffnen
andere wollen einfach nicht glauben dass
das virus gefährlich ist wie minister
nein ich werde nicht in angst leben
wir müssen rausgehen unser leben leben
wir müssen weitermachen ehrlich gesagt
ich glaube nicht dass dieses virus das
virus ist
ich glaube einfach nicht dass es so
schlimm ist wie sie gedacht haben
zwei ärzte sind heute auch gekommen und
christin sie halten dagegen
ich wollte das auch das gegenargument
aufgezeigt wird die menschen die heute
hier sind haben natürlich das recht zu
demonstrieren
sie sind aber nicht die mehrheit die
leute die ihnen widersprechen würden
sind zu hause
die meisten sind anderer meinung wir
sind wissenschaftler
wir halten uns an die wissenschaft und
wir wissen dass die us bürger zurzeit
leiden wir alle tun das mental
körperlich geistig wirtschaftlich vor
allem aber wir glauben wir sollten mit
der wiedereröffnung noch warten um das
sicher machen zu können
und dann eskaliert die situation
zwei demonstranten unterbrechen das
interview amerikaner leiden
ich habe kein geld zum essen die
menschen so zu hause eingesperrt und
werden wahnsinnig erik bruhn versucht
erst ruhig zu bleiben
danke dass sie ihre meinung hier teilen
ich verrate ihnen was meine meinung ist
die meinung der meisten us bürger
ich habe nicht genug geld zum essen wenn
sie angst haben bleiben sie doch zu
hause
sie können sich dafür entscheiden sie
sind intelligent genug wenn sie angst
haben krank zu werden kommen sie nicht
hierher
die maske witze nicht retten müsste erik
bruhn argumentiert erste gegen aber die
anderen sind lauter einfach viel lauter
die demonstranten sind sich sicher wer
am lautesten schreit der gewinnt das
soll jeder wissen hier und auch im netz
hört euch den sound am darf ist amerika
erlebt dass einmal großartig
die vereinigten staaten von amerika